même si les températures des derniers
jours sont moins élevé que les semaines
précédentes
les niveaux des rivières de la région
restent bas notamment à cause de
l'absence de pluie en loir-et-cher de
nouvelles restrictions viennent de
tomber notamment dans le secteur de la
six
l'arrosage des pelouses et jardins est
interdit l'arrosage des potagers prohibé
également entre 8 et 20 heures alors
pour ne pas aggraver la situation tout
le monde peut faire un effort quelques
conseils pratiques du côté du jardin
avec tristan weekly et aurélie renault
dans ce magasin de bricolage de la ville
aux dames le rayon arrosage et entretien
du jardin cartonne la quête des clients
les économies d'eau la solution
plébiscitée le récupérateur d'eau de
pluie le magasin en a vendu plus de 60
en un mois et l'investissement n'arrête
pas les clients cette invasion sur long
terme une q vous savez un peu à partir
d'une centaine d'euros vous avez une
cuve ça a vraiment garder sur des années
le beau temps est arrivé très vite donc
les gens voyais bien que yann périgny
d'eau donc voilà le fait d'avoir une
cuve dans son jardin va faire que dès
qu'il ya un petit peu de plus on car on
peut avoir de l'eau à disposition assez
facilement pour comprendre comment
arroser sans gaspiller l'eau direction
chambray-lès-tours nous sommes chez
pierre morand maraîchers en permaculture
depuis six ans bien entendu ici on
utilise le paillage pour garder
l'humidité mais pierre tient à nous
montrer la technique de loyat deux pots
en terre c'est léo mortiers dont la hora
le fond boucher le tout est enterrée
près des plantations la porosité des
parois permettra à l'autre de se
diffuser peu à peu la plante est ainsi
arrosé toute l'humilité va être
transmise à toute petite échelle dans la
terre pour le particulier les petits
maraîchers oui ça peut être une
technique fiable pour certaines un
certain légumes ou certains certaines
plan de les tomates les courgettes les
aubergines même sur les melons les
choses comme ça et du coup ça va
permettre de nous faire un stock et
ballet peau permettent de nous stocker
l'eau tout en restant étant lettre de
remplissage de cet oeil à suffiront pour
alimenter en eau un plant de tomate
un arrosage écologique datant de la rome
antique